The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help
MIT OpenCourseWare
continue to offer high quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation or to
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
ALAN EDELMAN: Hi, everybody.
I'm Alan Edelman.
And helped a little bit to
teach this class last year.
But happy to see that it's
going great this year.
So Professor Strang
came to teach 18.06.
Some of you may know the
introductory linear algebra
course.
And Professor Strang
came by and gave
this great demonstration
about the row rank
equals the column rank.
And I'm wondering if you did
that in this class at any time.
Or would they have seen that?
AUDIENCE: It's in the notes.
ALAN EDELMAN: It's in the notes.
Well, in any event, just as
Professor Strang walked out--
so here, I'll just grab this.
This is true.
I was actually going to
start writing the code
to do the quadrilateral, but
I didn't have enough time.
You can see me starting.
But here's the 0.5 for the
triangle, which was easy.
So what's the story with
Julia in this class?
Have they used it a
little, or a lot, or--
AUDIENCE: In the labs.
ALAN EDELMAN: In the
labs you've used Julia.
But that was just MATLAB.
So that was-- but OK.
So Professor Strang showed
this proof where he would--
he put down a 3 by 3 matrix.
It had rank two.
And he took the columns
that were-- the first two
columns were independent.
And it was easy to show the row
rank equals the column rank.
After Professor Strang
went out, I asked,
would that work for
the zero matrix?
So here's the zero matrix.
And since I'm not really
telling you the proof,
I'll just say, if I were to
make a matrix of the literally
independent columns of this
matrix, what would I do?
So zero might seem tricky.
It's not really that tricky.
But this is what I did
the moment you walked out.
So yeah, so I've got the 3 by 3
matrix, and I need to make a--
first step in whatever
the proof was,
I needed to take the
columns, the literally
independent columns
of this matrix,
and place them in a
matrix of their own.
What would I do?
It would be an empty matrix.
What would be the size
of this empty matrix?
Not exactly zero by zero.
Because where every column
is still in our 3, you see.
So the right answer--
I hope this makes sense--
is a 3 by 0 empty matrix.
And that's a concept that
exists in MATLAB, and in Julia,
and in Python, I
think, I'm sure,
and in any computer language.
So if you had a full
rank 3 by 3 matrix,
the linear independent
columns would be 3 by 3.
If you had a rank two,
it would be 3 by 2.
If I had a rank one
matrix, it would be 3 by 1.
So if I had no columns,
3 by 0 makes sense.
And to finish the proof,
again, I'm not telling these
students-- it's in
the notes apparently--
the next matrix
would be random 0, 3.
And of course you multiply
it and you get a 3
by 3 matrix of zeros.
So it's fun to see
that that proof still
works, even for the zero
matrix, without any real edge.
So that was just today.
The other thing is let me--
can I say a word or two about
recent stuff about Julia?
So I started to put
together a talk.
It's not really ready yet, but
I'll share it with you anyway.
So Google did the Julia
world a big favor last week.
I mean, this is huge.
So you all know machine
learning is hot.
That's probably why
you're here in this class.
I probably don't
have to tell you.
And yet I wouldn't be
surprised if a number of you
wished this whole class was in
Python or something, or maybe
MATLAB or something.
I don't doubt that
some of you might
have wanted that to happen.
And we get sort of bombarded
with, you know, why not Python.
Not so much MATLAB anymore.
But you know, why not Python is
sort of the issue that comes up
a lot.
And I could talk till
the cows come home,
but nobody would believe me.
But Google came out
last week and said
that when it comes
to machine learning,
there really are two languages
that are powerful enough
to do machine learning--
to do machine learning kinds
of things that you want to do.
And in some sense, the
rest of today's lecture
that I'm going to give will be
maybe illustrations of this.
But if you want, you can go
and look at their blog here.
What they do is they basically
sort of start the race
with a whole bunch of
programming languages.
There's Python.
There's R. Java, JavaScript.
They sort of look at
all of these languages.
And if you read the
blog, you'll see.
But we're going to filter
them out on technical merits.
And right away, a lot
of them disappear,
including Python and Java.
And if you go to
the blog, you'll
see they spend a great deal
of time on the Python story.
Because they know
that people are
going to want to hear that one.
I mean, people want
to be convinced.
And so there's actually
multiple screens
full on the reason why
Python is just not good
enough for machine learning.
So they leave four
languages left--
Julia, Swift, C++, and Rust.
And then if you go to the
next part of the blog,
they filter on usability.
And then two more
sort of bite the dust.
So C++ and Rust disappeared.
And then they go on to say
that these are the only two
languages they feel are
appropriate for machine
learning.
And they put this
nice quote that it
shares many common values.
And they actually go on about
what machine learning really
needs.
And I'd recommend
you look at it.
And then finally,
of course, they're
going to push Swift,
which they should.
So they had somewhere-- blah,
blah-- about more people
are using Swift.
Maybe it's true.
I don't know.
So they really said is they're
more familiar with Swift
than Julia, which, you
know, if I was speaking,
I'd say I'm more familiar
with Julia than Swift.
So maybe it's fair.
And then I started to
put a little cartoon
on the psychology of
programming languages,
just because it's
sort of something
that I bump into
with all the time.
People always say all
languages are equally good.
It doesn't really matter.
But the truth is if you mention
a language that you're not
using yet, you're
going to tune it out,
at least until
Google comes along.
So that that's where we are.
OK, enough about--
I just put this together.
I was testing it out on you.
All right.
So now let me do two
more mathematical things.
So the first thing I
want to do is talk to you
about forward mode
automatic differentiation.
So have you done any automatic
differentiation in this course?
AUDIENCE: Very little.
ALAN EDELMAN: OK, so I
think this is pretty fun.
I hope you'll like it.
I have a notebook in
Julia on forward mode
automatic differentiation.
And this notebook came
together because I
was trying to understand
what the big deal was
for a long time.
And I had a little trouble.
I mean, it's the usual story
where on a line-by-line level,
it's easy to understand.
But what's the big deal part?
That's sometimes the
harder thing to grasp.
And the first notebook
I'm going to show you
is sort of the
result of my trying
to grasp what was the
real picture here.
And the second thing--
I think I'll just do
it on the blackboard.
It's not even really ready yet,
but I'll sort of unleash it
on you folks anyway--
is to show you how to do a
particular example of backward
mode automatic
differentiation, the
that you see in the neural net.
And I guess you have seen
some neural nets here?
AUDIENCE: Yep.
ALAN EDELMAN So I think by now
everybody's seen neural nets.
I think two years from now,
it'll be in high schools.
And three years from there,
it will be in kindergarten.
I don't know.
Neural nets seem to be sort of--
they're not that
hard to understand.
OK, so let me start things off.
And really, the two things that
I'd love to convince you of
is--
let me just find-- here's
my auto diff thing.
The two things that I
really want to convince you
of-- and maybe you already
believe some of this--
is one, that-- well, maybe
you don't believe this yet--
but that the language matters
in a mathematical sense.
The right computer language
can do more for you
than just take some algorithm on
a blackboard and implement it.
It could do much more.
And this is something that I
hope to give a few examples of.
And the other thing that
I bet you all believe now,
because you've
been in this class,
is that linear algebra is
the basis for everything.
Every course should start
with linear algebra.
I mean, to me, it feels like a
unfortunate accident of history
that linear algebra came too
late for too many reasons.
And so very often, things
that would be better done
with linear algebra are not.
And I mean, to me, it feels like
doing physics without calculus.
I just don't get it.
I know high schools do that.
But it just seems wrong.
To me, all of
engineering, all of-- it
should all be linear algebra.
I mean, I just believe
that-- almost all.
Maybe not all.
But quite a lot.
More than most people
realize, I would say.
OK, so let me start with
automatic differentiation.
So I'm going to
start by this story
by telling you that I
would go to conferences.
I would go to numerical
analysis conferences.
I would hear people talk about
automatic differentiation.
I'm going to be honest.
I was reading my email.
I was tuned out.
Like, who cares about--
I know calculus.
You could teach a
computer to do it.
It seems pretty easy to me.
I mean, I'm sure there
are technical details.
But it didn't seem that
interesting to teach a computer
to differentiate.
I sort of figured that
it was the same calculus
that I learned when I
took a calculus class.
You know, you
memorize this table.
You teach it to a computer.
You learn the chain rule,
and the product rule,
and the quotient rule.
And bump, the computer
is doing just what I
would do with paper and pencil.
So big deal.
I didn't pay attention.
And in any event, there
was this little neuron
in the back of my brain that
said, hey, maybe I'm wrong.
Maybe it's doing
finite differences,
you know, the sort
of thing where
you take the dy by the dx.
In some numerical way, you
do the finite differences.
And in numerical
analysis, they're
supposed to tell you if h is too
big, you get truncation error.
If you have h too small,
you get round off error.
And the truth is nobody ever
tells you what's a good h.
But you go to a
numerical analysis class
hoping somebody would tell you.
But in any event,
so I thought maybe
it was that kind of a
numerical finite difference.
And I think the
big surprise for me
was that automatic
differentiation was neither
the first nor the second
thing, that there's actually
a third thing, something
different, that's neither
the first or the second.
And I found that fascinating.
And maybe I'll even tell you
how it hit me in the head
that this was the story.
Because I really wasn't
paying attention.
But I love the singular
value decomposition.
I'm glad to see that people are
drawing parabolas and quarter
circles and figuring out what
the minimum SVD value is.
The singular value is just--
it's just God's gift to mankind.
It's just a good factorization.
One of the things I was
playing with with Julia
was to calculate the
Jacobian matrix for the SVD.
So you know, all
matrix factorizations
are just changes of variables.
So if you have a square
matrix, n by n, the SVD--
I'm sure you know this-- is the
U matrix is really n times n
mass 1 over 2 variable.
So is the V. And the
sigma has got n variables.
Put it all together,
you got n squared.
So it's just a
change of variables.
And every time you
change variables,
you can form that big matrix, n
squared by n squared of dy dx,
compute its determinant,
and get an answer.
And I wanted to know--
I actually knew the
theoretical answer for that.
And I wanted to see
a computer confirm
that theoretical answer.
And I spoke to some
people who wrote auto diff
in non-Julia languages.
And I was surprised
by the answer.
They said, oh, yeah.
We could teach the
answer to our system.
I said, what do you mean
you could teach the answer?
Why doesn't it just
compute the answer?
Why do you have to
teach the answer?
I thought that was all wrong.
Because in Julia, we
didn't have to teach it.
It would actually calculate it.
And then I started to
understand a little bit more
about what auto diff was doing
and what Julia was doing.
And so this is how this
notebook came to be.
So let me start--
I'm saying too much.
Let me start with an example
that might kind of hit home.
So I'm going to
compute the square root
of x, a real simple example.
You know, a square
root's pretty easy.
I'm going to take one of
the oldest algorithms known
to mankind, the Babylonian
square root algorithm.
It says start with
a starting guess t.
Maybe it's a little bit too
low for the square root of x.
Get x over t.
So that would be too large.
Go ahead and take the
average, and repeat.
OK.
This is equivalent
to a Newton's method
for taking the square root.
And it's been known for
millennia to mankind.
So it's not the latest
research, by any means,
for computing square roots.
But it works very effectively.
And here's a little
Julia code that
actually will implement it.
It probably looks like
code in any language.
So I'm going to start off at 1.
So literally, I'm
just going to take
1 plus the starting value
of x and divide by 2.
And then I'm going to repeat.
OK?
And we can check that
the algorithm works.
Here's alpha is pi.
And so I'll take the
Babylonian algorithm
and compare it to
Julia's built in.
And you see it gives
the right answer.
Here it is with the
square root of two.
It's always good to
check your code works.
OK?
I like to see
things graphically,
so I ran the algorithm
for lots of values of x.
And I love doing this.
I kind of wish that
in the previous talk--
if I'd only worked
fast enough, I
wanted to build a
little GUI where
I can move the points
in front of your eyes.
Maybe you have one in MATLAB.
I bet you do.
But I wanted to build it.
But I didn't get
there fast enough.
But here this is
the sort of thing.
And I like to see
the convergence.
And so you could see
the digits converging,
the parabola on the bottom.
The block is the
square root, of course.
So there it is.
There's the
Babylonian algorithm.
I would like to get the
derivative of square root.
But the rules of the
game are I'm not going
to type method 1 or method 2.
I'm not going to do-- you'll
never see me type 1/2 x
to the minus 1/2.
Right?
You all know that's
the derivative.
I will not type that.
I will not.
It's not going to come
anywhere from Julia.
OK.
And the second thing
is I'm not going
to do a finite difference.
All right?
I'm going to get
that square root,
but not by sort of
either of the two things
that I'm sure you
would think of.
Right?
Here's how I'm going to do it.
And I'm going to do a
little bit of Julia code.
There'll be eight
lines of Julia.
But I'm not going to completely
say how it works yet.
I'll keep you in suspense
for maybe about five minutes.
And then I'll tell
you how it works.
All right?
So here's eight lines of
Julia code that will get me
the square root.
So in these three lines, I'm
going to create a Julia type.
I'm going to call it a D
for a dual number, which
is a name that goes back at
least a century, maybe more.
So I'm going to create a D type.
And all this is is
a pair of floats.
So it's a tuple with
It's going to be some
sort of numerical function
and derivative pair.
So three of my eight lines is to
create a D. In Julia language,
this means to use a
subtype of a number,
so we're going to
treat it like a number.
Right?
We want to be able
to add, multiply,
and divide these ordered pairs.
But it's just a pair of numbers.
Don't let the Julia scare you.
It's just a function
derivative numerical pair.
OK?
And what's these
other five lines?
Well, I want to teach it the
sum rule and the quotient rule.
So you all remember
the same rule.
I guess that's the easy one.
The quotient rule--
I still have my teacher
from high school ringing
in the back of my ear.
The denominator times the
derivative of the numerator
and minus the
numerator-- you all
have that jingle
in your brain, too?
I bet you do.
divided by the
denominator squared.
Can't even get it
out of my head.
So there's the quotient rule.
And so what are we doing
in these five lines?
Well, first of all, I want
to overlook plus and divide
and a few other things.
And Julia wants me
to say, are you sure?
So the way you say
are you sure is
that I'm going to
import plus and divide.
Because it would be
dangerous to play with plus.
So here I'm going to
plus two dual numbers.
We're going to add the
function and the derivatives.
Divide two dual numbers.
We're going to divide the
function values and denominator
times the numerator, blah,
blah, blah, you get it.
OK.
That's six of the eight lines.
The seventh line is, if
I have a dual number,
I wanted to convert it.
You know how the wheels are
embedded in the complexes?
We have to tell Julia
to take the dual number
and stick a zero in.
And then dual numbers
and regular numbers
can play nicely together.
And this actually
is the thing that
actually says, if I have
a dual number and a number
in operation, promote them so
they'll work as dual numbers--
so eight lines of code.
So the first thing I'm
going to tell you is I'm
going to remind you I never
typed 1/2 x to the minus 1/2.
Do you agree?
No one-- I'm not
importing any packages.
It's not like it's
coming in from the--
I'm not sneaking it
in from the side.
There's no one half
x to the minus 1/2.
And there's certainly not
any numerical derivatives,
either, right?
Arguably, a rule
that almost feels
symbolic, the quotient
rule and the addition rule.
But no numerical finite
differences at all here.
OK.
So first of all,
let me show you here
that I'm applying the Babylonian
algorithm without rewriting
code to a dual number now.
Before we applied it to numbers.
But now I'm going to play
it to this dual number
that I just invented.
I'm going to apply it at 49,
1, because I know the answer.
And then I'm going
to compare it with--
I'm taking one half
of the square root
of x just for
comparison purposes
and not in my own algorithm.
And of course, you see
that I'm getting magically
the right answer without ever--
so you should wonder,
how did I do that?
How did I get the derivative?
We could take any
number you like.
Here's 100.
If you prefer to see a number
like pi, we can do that.
I mean, we can do
whatever you like.
It's going to work.
So there you see this is
the square root of pi.
And this would be 1/2 over the
square root of pi numerically.
So when you see it matches
these numbers to enough digits,
in fact, all the
digits, actually.
Yeah.
So the thing magically worked.
You should all be wondering,
how did that happen?
I didn't rewrite any code.
I actually wrote a code to
just compute the square root.
I never wrote a code to compute
the root of a square root.
And by the way, this is a
little bit of the Julia magic
that we're pushing numerically.
That very often in
this world, people
will write a code
to do something,
and then if you want
to do something more,
like get a derivative,
somebody writes another code.
With Julia, very
often, you can actually
keep to the original code.
And if you just use it
properly and intelligently,
you can do magic things
without writing new codes.
And you'll see this
again in a little bit.
But here's the derivative of--
this is the plot of 1/2 over
the square root of x in black.
And again, you could see
the convergence over here.
All right.
Well, I'm still not going to
show you why it works just yet.
I promise I will in just
probably a few minutes more.
But what I will do first is
I'd like to show you something
that most people
will never look at.
I never look at it.
I want to show you-- here's
the same Babylonian code.
I want to show you the
assembler for the computation
of the derivative.
So I'm going to run
Babylonian on a dual number.
And we're going to look here.
And I don't know if anybody
here reads assembler.
I'm betting there is zero
or one of you actually
reads this stuff.
How many of you read assembler?
OK.
It wasn't 0, 1.
We had a half.
Right there's half.
He's kind of going like this.
Here's zero.
Here's one.
He's like this.
OK.
So I think 0, 1 is
like the record.
But I'll bet you'll believe
me if I tell you that, when
you have short assembler like
this and it's not very long,
then you have efficient code.
It's very tight.
It will run very fast.
So whatever this thing
is doing, it's short.
And this you won't get
from any other language.
If you did try to do the
same thing in Python,
I promise you there
would be screens
and screens and
screens full of stuff,
even if you could get it.
So here's the Babylonian
algorithm on the dual number.
And here it is in
assembler, and it's short.
So the other thing
that I'm saying
is not only does it work, but
Julia also makes it efficient.
So before I finally tell
you what's really going on
and why it works,
I'm going to grab
a Python symbolic package, which
will work nicely with Julia.
And I'm going to run the
same code through the Python
symbolic and show you what--
these are the
iterations that you get.
So you actually
see the iterations
towards the square root.
And here are the iterations
of the derivative that's
actually being calculated.
And the key point here
is, of course, this
is a symbolic computation.
We're not doing a
symbolic computation.
This is mathematically
equivalent to the function
we would get if we were to,
like, plot it or something.
But of course,
symbolic computation
is very inefficient.
I mean, you get these
big coefficients.
I mean, look at this number.
What is this?
5 million or something?
Anyway, you get
these big numbers,
these even bigger numbers here.
Look at these huge
numbers, right?
It takes a lot of storage
dragging these x's along.
There's a big drag on memory.
I mean, this is
not the way that--
this is why we do
numerical computation.
But the Babylonian algorithm,
in the absence of any round off,
is equivalent to computing--
above the line, it's computing
the square root here.
And then below here,
these are the iterates
towards the derivative.
So it's not actually calculating
1/2 x to the minus 1/2.
It's actually doing
something iterative
that is approximating
1/2 x to the minus 1/2.
All right.
Well, let me tell you now.
Let me sort of reveal
what's going on,
just so that I can
kind of show you
how it's getting the answer.
And like I said, it was the
SVD that sort of convinced me
how this was happening.
Because the SVD is also
an iterative algorithm,
like this Babylonian
square root.
But it's easier to show you
the point with the Babylonian
square root.
So I'm going to do something
that I would never want to do,
which is explicitly write
a derivative Babylonian
algorithm.
And what I'm doing
is I'm going to take
the derivative in respect to
x of every line on my code.
So if every even or odd line--
I never know what's
even or odd anymore.
But the original line of
code had 1 plus x over 2.
Now I'm going to
take the derivative.
I'll get a half.
Here I had this line of code.
If I take the derivative
I'll, use the quotient rule,
and this would be
the derivative.
If I run this code, what
I'm effectively doing
is I'm just using good old
plus and times and divide,
nothing fancy.
There's not a square
root to be seen.
But what I'm doing is,
as I run my algorithm,
I'm also running--
I'm actually computing
the derivative as I go.
So if I have this
infinite algorithm that's
going to converge
to the square roots,
the derivative algorithm will
converge to the derivative
of the square roots.
But I'm not using anything
other than plus, minus, times,
and divide to make that happen.
So if you rewrite
any code at all,
you could have any
code-- iterative,
finite, it doesn't matter.
If you just take
the derivatives back
to your variable of
every line of your code,
then you can get
a derivative out.
And as I said, it's not
a symbolic derivative,
like, you know, all
of 18.01, or whatever,
wherever we teach
calculus these days.
And it's not a
numerical derivative
like in the numerical courses,
the 18.3, axyz's, whatever.
It's a different beast.
It's using the quotient
rule and the addition rule
at every step of the
way to get the answer.
Here's this
dBabylonian algorithm.
You could see it running.
It gives the right answer.
Oop, I have to execute the code
first to get the right answer.
But if you see, it
gives the right answer.
Oh, I was just in Istanbul and
they challenged me to do sine.
I forget about that.
It's still in my notebook.
I did it in front of everybody.
It worked.
I got a cosine.
OK.
But let me pass all of that.
So let me go back and tell you
then how is this all working.
Well, what's happening--
let's go back
to the eight lines of
code, and now, maybe, you
can see what's happening.
Where's my eight lines of
code from the very beginning?
And I've got to watch the time.
I want to show you this
one other thing, too.
So hopefully, I'll have
enough time to do that.
But here, let's see.
Where are my eight
lines of code?
Where are they?
Here we go.
Here are the eight
lines of code.
So what I'm doing is, instead
of rewriting all your code
by taking the derivative of
every line the human way,
I'm saying that why
can't the software just
do this in some automatic way?
And this is where the automatic
differentiation comes in.
And in the old, old days,
when people-- and all
the numerical code
was in Fortran,
there would be the source
to source translators
that would actually input code
and output derivatives of code.
The Julia way, the
more modern way,
is to let the git compiler
kind of do that for you.
So here, I needed
plus and divide.
Of course, I would want
to add minus and times.
But you just add a couple
of things and then bump,
you don't have to
rewrite the dBabylonian.
Because the Babylonian,
with this type,
will just do the work for you.
OK?
And that's where the magic
of a good piece of software
will have it.
So you don't have to
write a translator.
You don't have to hand write it.
You just give the rules and
you let the computer do it.
Right?
And that's what computers
are supposed to be good at.
So that's what's happening.
All right.
So that's forward mode
automatic differentiation.
I've got 10 minutes
to go backwards.
But let me see if
there's any-- anybody
have any questions about this?
It's really magic, right?
But it's pretty wonderful magic.
And I don't know what you've
heard about machine learning,
but to be honest, machine
learning these days,
it's forgetting about whether
humans will be useless, which
I don't believe by the way.
But the big thing
about machine learning
is that it's really
just a big optimization.
That's all it is, right?
One big minimum maximum
problem where you've all
known from calculus
that what you need to do
is take derivatives.
You know, set them
to zero, right?
In the case of multivariate,
it's a gradient.
You set it to zero.
And so really all of
this machine learning,
all the big stories and
everything in the end
comes down to automatic
differentiation.
It's sort of like the
workhorse of the whole thing.
And so if we could have
a language that gives you
that workhorse in a good way,
then machine learning really
sort of benefits from that.
So I hope you all see the big
picture of machine learning.
It really does come down
to taking derivatives.
That's the end-- that's
how you optimize.
Any quick questions?
Otherwise, I'm going
to switch topics,
and I'm going to move
to the blackboard.
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: Does the same
thing happen for second order
derivatives as well?
ALAN EDELMAN: There is a
trick that basically lets
you go to higher orders, yeah.
You can basically make it
a combo of two first order
derivatives.
So yeah, it can be done.
Did you have a question?
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
Is this notation of
[INAUDIBLE],, and is this
only really used for computing
different orders of derivatives
or are there other examples?
ALAN EDELMAN: Well,
for using types?
AUDIENCE: Or
specifically, I guess,
the way that you did through
this whole presentation,
just this generalized other--
ALAN EDELMAN: So it's the
biggest trick in the world.
It's not this little thing.
The idea of making a
type to do what you--
I mean, did you see Kronecker
products in this class?
AUDIENCE: No.
ALAN EDELMAN: No?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
ALAN EDELMAN: OK.
Let me see.
What would you
have seen in this?
Did you see tridiagonal
matrices, your favorite?
OK.
So here.
So here's a built in type.
Let's say n is--
oh, n doesn't have to be 4.
I'm going to create
a strang matrix,
if I could spell it right.
And it's going to be a
SymTridiagonal, which
is a Julia type.
And we will create two
times ones of n and minus
ones of n minus 1.
Here's a type.
I mean, this is built in.
But you could have created
it yourself just as easily.
And I don't like calling this--
it's certainly not
a dense matrix.
And I don't like calling
it a sparse matrix.
I prefer to call it
a structured matrix.
Though the word sparse,
it's a little tricky here.
But the reason why I don't like
to call this a sparse matrix
is because we're not
storing indices in any--
I mean, there a lot of fancy
schemes for storing indices
for sparse matrices.
Well, all we store
is a diagonal vector.
There's the 2s on the diagonal.
There's this 4 vector
with four twos.
And here's a three vector
for the off diagonal.
And you know, you don't
have it twice, by the way.
Most sparse matrix structures
would have the minus vector
twice, the super and the sub.
But really, only the core
information that's needed
is stored.
And in a way, one uses types
in Julia to basically--
you only store what
you need, not more.
And then you define
your operations to work.
So for example, if I were to
take a strang inverse times,
oh, anything, times a random 4.
I'm going to do a linear solve.
You would want to use a
special [INAUDIBLE] that
knew that the matrix was
a symmetric tridiagonal.
So it's a big story of being
able to create types and use
them for your own purposes
without any wastage.
And this is the sort of thing
that while you can do it
in languages like Python,
in MATLAB, if you were
able the assembler-- and MATLAB
would never let you, Python,
you just would
regret it-- but you
would see just how much
overhead there is in doing this.
So there would be
no performance gain.
But in a way, this is
what you want to do.
You want to use these things
to match the mathematics.
And so that's really the
nice thing to be able to do.
All right.
I only have five minutes.
I don't know if I'm
going to pull this off.
But let me see if
I could give you
the main idea in five
minutes of over immersed mode
differentiations.
But here, as long as you are
familiar with neural networks,
let me see if I can
do this very quickly.
I'm going to start with scalars.
OK?
I'm going to do a neural
network of all scalars.
But only for simplicity,
for starters,
but I think you're going to
see that this can generalize
to vectors and matrices, which
are real neural networks.
So what I'm going to
do is I want to imagine
that we have our inputs.
We'll have a bunch of
scalar weights and biases.
So here's W1, and I'll
go up to wn and bn.
All right?
So we have a bunch of
weights and biases here.
OK?
And we'll also have an x1,
which will sort of start off
our neural network.
And we're going to compute--
I'll write it in sort of
Julia-like or MATLAB-like
notation, for i
equals 1 through n.
I will update x by taking some
function of my current input,
maybe something like this.
And what function h to use?
I don't really care too much.
In the old days,
people used to talk
about the sigmoid function.
Nowadays, it's the
maximum of 0 and t
that gets used all the time.
It's got this
ridiculous name RELU,
which I really can't stand.
But anyway, the
rectified linear unit.
But in any event,
I mean, it's just
the function that's t of t is
greater than or equal to 0.
0, if not.
But whatever function you like.
And here I'm just
going to update.
OK.
And then ultimately, you
might also have some data y.
And you would like
to, if everything's
a scalar, like I
said, this could
be generalized pretty quickly.
But what we can do is
we can minimize, say,
1/2 y minus xm squared.
And you're going to want
to find the data that
would minimize that.
All this generalizes to
matrices and vectors, which
is what most neural nets do.
OK?
And since I'm not going
to have a lot of time,
maybe I can just sort
of cut to the chase.
If I were to differentiate
the key line here,
I got a little
bit of Julia here.
But if I were to differentiate
the key line, what would
I write?
I would write--
well, here, actually,
let me use the usual notation.
Let me have delta I be the
h prime of wxi plus bi.
OK?
So that's delta i.
And then you can see that
the dxi plus 1 is delta i.
And I'll have dwi xi plus
dxi wi plus dbi would
be the differential.
This would be how--
so I'm almost done,
that's the good news.
So if I make a little change--
I like to think of this
as, like, 0.001 changes.
I don't like infinitesimals.
I like 0.001.
That's how I think of them.
But you make a little change
here, a little change here,
a little change here.
You get a change here.
You'll get this linear
this linear function
of the perturbations here
gives you perturbations here.
OK?
Well, I've only got one minute.
So I'm going to write all
this out with linear algebra,
because everything is
better when written out
with linear algebra.
So I'm going to
write down that--
I'm going to write
down that I'm actually
interested in the last element.
But dx dn plus 1
is going to equal
and I'm going to have a
couple of matrices here.
Let me just sort of get
the structure right.
This will dx2, dxn plus 1 again.
Sorry for the squishing.
But here-- in fact, I'd
like to use block matrices
a little bit.
So here I'm going
to have dw1 db1.
I'm going to put the bias
together-- sorry for the mess.
But dwn dbn.
And Julia lets you
make block matrices.
And you can actually
use them directly.
There'd be a special
type right there.
OK?
And then what goes
here you could actually
see what it would be.
It would be--
I hope I'm doing it right.
But there'd be a delta
1x1 and a delta NxN
And this would be
a diagonal matrix.
OK?
And then what do
I have over here?
Here I'd have the delta w's.
And if you check you'll
see that this will be--
I'm not going to get the indices
right, and I don't have time.
So I'm just going to
write it like this.
And now I'm just
going to give you
the end of the story,
because I've run out of time.
You could write
all this as dx is
equal to a diagonal matrix
times the derivative
of the parameters plus a
lower triangle or matrix
times the x again.
And so if you want
to solve this,
linear algebra just
does the propagation.
You have I minus
L dx is DdP or dx
will be I minus L inverse DDP.
And if I only want the
last element-- let's
say en is the vector that
pulls out the last element,
then this is all I'm going to
need to get all my derivatives.
And what's the
moral of the story?
I apologize for going
one minute over.
But the moral of the story is
instead of back propagating
through your own hard
work, you probably
know that when you solve
a lower triangular matrix,
people will read written code
that back solves the lower
triangular matrix.
The back, the big back
piece, has already
been implemented for you.
Why reinvent the wheel in if
the back-- if linear algebra
already has the back, you see?
And so if you just do
this, and you do it
in a language that lets
you get full performance,
you don't need to do
your own backpropagation.
Because a simple backslash
will do it for you.
So I apologize for going over.
I don't know if Professor
Strang had some final words.
But anyway, linear algebra
is the secret to everything.
That's the big message.
AUDIENCE: OK.
[APPLAUSE]
GILBERT STRANG: Well, since it's
our last two minutes, or minus
two minutes of 18.065.
I hope you guys enjoyed it.
I certainly enjoyed
it, as you could tell.
Teaching this class,
seeing how it would go,
and writing about it.
So I'll let you know
as about the writing.
And meanwhile, I'll
get your writing
on the projects, which
I appreciate very much.
And of course, grades are
going to come out well.
And I hope you've enjoyed it.
So thank you all.
You're right.
Thanks.
[APPLAUSE]